عائشه افغاني طالبه جامعيه توجهت الى
العمل في احدى الشركات الخاصه بتعليم
الحرف اليدويه التي تقوم بها السيدات عاده
في المجتمع الافغاني وتتعلم الخياطه
والتطريز
قبل التحولات السياسيه في البلد كنت طالبه
ادرس ولم اكن اعمل انذاك وبعد التحولات
حرمت من مواصله الدراسه اتيت الى هذه
الشركه لاعمل حتى اساعد اسرتي اقتصاديا
السيده فريده نوري مسؤوله في غرفه التجاره
والصناعه النسائيه تطالب السلطات في كابول
بفتح الدهاليز جويه وبريه لتجاره السيدات
الافغانيات الى خارج البلد حتى يتمكن من
اقامه معارض لمنتجات النساء الافغانيات في
الخارج افلاطق دوله يطلب من الحكومات
تقديم اماكن
وامكانيات للعاملات اللوتيه عملنا ويقومنا
بمصنوعات ومنتجات لعرض هذه المنتجات حتى
يتمكن من عرضها وبيعها بسهوله
بحسب وزاره الصناعه والتجاره فان القطاع
الخاص يشهد زياده بنسبه 66% في الاستثمار
والاقتصاد للسيدات الافغانيات السيد عبد
السلام جواد المتحدث باسم الوزاره يقول ان
الوزاره تسعى للتقديم فرص وامكانيات افضل
لعمل المراه في القطاع الخاص
قمنا بحل مشاكل كثيره كانت تواجه السيدات
في القطاع الخاص كالحصول على تصريح العمل
والحصول على قطعه ارض ونقل المنتجات من
مقاطعه الى اخرى تطالب رائدات الاعمال من
السلطات في كابول بتزويدهن بالتسهيلات
اللازمه في قطاع الاعمال وتقديم فرص العمل
لهن وتشجيعهن على الكفاءه الذا اقتصاديا
يؤكد الاجتماعيون والاقتصاديون والافغاني
على ان وجود المراه في المجال الاستثماري
والاقتصاديه للبلاد يمكن ان يكون له اثر
ايجابي في الحد من الفقر في بلد يعتبر بلد
الارامل والايتان
العربيه كابول لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات